first two days of the regular season the
bench keep putting in buckets at the
right time
let's touch on limit I suggest we do
your job and Gus gets all the way to the
rim
he's got 32 adjust the ball the ball
that's a lot let's put box that trailer
in the round with the stop thunder back
up to a 19 point lead
Suns call it top tricky fence the turns
[Applause]
jumped off the trampoline about the
long-playing but Terence Ferguson from
any time that we see Russell Westbrook
doing this play deterrence partisan and
Russ can tell you boy he was up there
but was already on his mood and Billy
had time to pull back
[Applause]
rustle scratches the back of the day
cosel's going to extremely whatever you
give him well that's what a lot of the
wizards opponents whose Westbrook comes
up with a steal there and throws it down
he pitches that their retainers close in
that steal that Paul George forgot
numbers also do on one Westbrook
perfect transitions this is some serious
meditation this beautiful beautiful
fast-break basketball watching Russell
with the basketball as he settles to
battle over with Florida half to go in
the second quarter good defenses
Westbrook skipped out that lob pass a
good job funny Kevin Durant as well and
did a good job baby
that turnover Russell Westbrook see what
scrub cans the three
this is good to keep its once again by
the Thunder would just start to take
control of this know exactly what to do
with it why scrub
to the rim and look at Dodgers playing
out of his mind
Adams in traffic it's the live in the
slam it was called it but before the
last timeout on the turnover that
Westbrook hat
he was upset with Adam that he didn't
come over and post up on the strong side
getting good looks old
bad pass stolen by Westbrook Westbrook
measures throws it up for Paul George
good on selfish play though George call
for the technical for hanging on the rim
look for himself up yep
[Applause]
what's good
[Applause]
I'm gonna go smooth walking before the
game and says listen this is a quiet
guys he turns it over let's nip on the
are you happy you're one in five in your
last six you start this game hot stale
how about that one came from Noah and
room service at the other end Westbrook
with a primal yell to punctuate is gonna
say that's nasty brats
especially their clothes at I'm nauseous
awesome
of course mrs. Wong's up but you saw
nothing but me notices hi who's the 30
as the shot clock was winding down I
think years from now people are gonna
look at Westbrook stats and think just
how he did that you score quickly and
then you score quickly you get into the
defense and force them the palm timeout
undergone for the three-ball Brandt yes
and it's at one point content assume
they're gonna call timeout now that are
thriving right now the NBA Billy
D'Angelo Russell for the nets
there's a foul and one opportunity
[Applause]
here's Westbrook picking it up can't let
him get the ball a half-court with six
seconds to me there's that's a lot of
time to get something done
Stephen Adams put Westbrook at the
buzzer
I'm doing Defensive Player of the Year
as well look at hook another turnover
[Applause]
it's Westbrook try to defend stuff
shrewder Leonard missed the fall Oh
Russell with the loose ball they can get
the time Westbrook on the drive
[Applause]
hi folks now that is a hard push
Westbrook full speed splitting the
defender and a beautiful left hand
finished 38 points tonight for Russell
Westbrook to go along with 10 rebounds
and six assists but no bucket more
important and then this one right here
from Toronto's perspective as quick
wants to push to the Thunder
and you see Westbrook evaded one into
[Applause]
possessions
[Applause]
we just watch history here we administer
first time I ever see somebody
yes wanna be this what up it's your boy
Adam left coach you like that content I
know you like that content hit subscribe
for more of it from Bleacher Report